let's say i have a bag and in that bag i
am going to put some green cubes in that
bag and in particular i am going to put
i am going to put eight green cubes i'm
also going to put some spheres spheres
in that bag let's say i'm going to put
nine spheres
and these are the green spheres i'm also
going to put some yellow cubes in that
bag
some yellow cubes
i'm going to put
five of those and i'm also going to put
some yellow spheres in this bag
yellow spheres and let's say i put seven
of those i'm going to stick them all in
this bag and then i'm going to shake
that bag and i'm going to pour it out
and i'm going to look at the first
object that falls out of that bag and
what i want to think about in this video
is what are the probabilities of getting
different types of objects so for
example what is the probability
what is the probability of getting a
cube a cube of any of any color
so what is the probability of getting a
cube well to think about that we should
think about what are or this is one way
to think about it what are all of the
equally likely possibilities that might
pop out of the bag well we have 8 plus 9
is 17 17 plus 5 is 22 22 plus 7 is 29 so
we have 29 objects there are 29 objects
in the bag did i do that right this is
14 yep 29 objects so let's draw all of
the possible objects and i'll do this as
i'll represent it as this big area
i'll represent it as this big area right
over here so these are all the possible
objects there are 29 possible objects so
there's 29 equal possibilities for the
outcome of my experiment of
seeing what pops out of that bag
assuming that it's equally likely for a
cube or sphere to pop out first and how
many of them meet our constraint of
being a cube
well i have eight green cubes and i have
five yellow cubes so there are total of
13 cubes and so let me draw that set of
cubes so there's 13 cubes i could draw
it like this
there are 13
13 cubes
this right here is the set of cubes this
area and i'm not drawing it exact i'm
approximating represents the set of all
the cubes so the probability of getting
a cube is the number of events that meet
our criteria so there's 13 possible
cubes that have an equal likely chance
of popping out
over all of the possible equally likely
events which are 29 that
includes the cubes and the spheres
now let's ask a different question what
is the probability of getting a yellow a
yellow object either a cube or a sphere
so once again how many things meet our
conditions here well we have five plus
seven there's 12
there's 12 yellow objects in the bag so
we have 29 equally likely possibilities
i'll do that same color
we have 29 equally likely possibilities
and of those 12 meet our criteria
so let's or by so let's say let me draw
12 right over here
do my best attempt so let's say it looks
something like
so the set of yellow objects they're 12
they're 12 objects that are yellow
so the 12 that meet our conditions are
12 over all the possibilities 29 so the
probability of getting cube 13 29's
probability of getting a yellow 12 29
now let's ask something a little bit
more interesting what is the probability
what is the probability of getting a
yellow cube so i'll put it in yellow so
we care about the color now so this
thing is yellow
what is the probability of or as my son
would say lello what is the probability
of getting a yellow cube
well there's 29 equally likely
possibilities
there's 29 equally likely possibilities
and of those 29 equally likely
possibilities
five of those are yellow cubes or low
cubes
five of them so the probability is 5 29s
and where would we see that on this venn
diagram that i've drawn in this venn
diagram this is just a way to visualize
the different probabilities and they
become interesting when you start
thinking about where sets overlap or
even where they don't overlap so here
we're thinking about things that are
members of the set yellow so they're in
this set and they're cubes so this area
right over here that's that's the
overlap of these two sets so this area
right over here this represents things
that are both yellow and cubes because
they are inside both circles so this
right over here let me write it let me
write it over here so there's five
objects that are both yellow
yellow and
yellow and cubes
now let's ask and this is probably the
most interesting thing to ask
what is the probability
what is the probability of getting
something that is yellow
or
that is yellow or a cube a cube of any
color
a cube of any color probability of
getting something that is yellow or a
cube of any color well we still know
that the denominator here is going to be
29 these are all of the equally likely
possibilities that might jump out of the
bag but what are the possibilities that
meet our conditions
well one way to think about it one way
to think about it is
well the probably there's 12 things that
would meet the yellow condition so that
would be this entire circle right over
here 12 things that meet the yellow
condition so this right over here is 12.
this is the number
of yellow
that is 12. and then to that we can't
just add the number of cubes because if
we add the number of cubes we've already
counted these five these five are
counted as part of this 12. one way to
think about it is there are seven yellow
objects that are not cubes those are the
spheres there are five yellow objects
that are cubes and then there are eight
cubes that are not yellow that's one way
to think about it so when we counted
this 12 the number of yellow we counted
all of this so we can't just add the
number of cubes to it because then we
would count this the middle part again
so then we have to essentially count
cubes the number of cubes which is 13
13. so number of cubes
number of cubes
number of cubes and we'll have to
subtract out this middle section right
over here let me do this so subtract out
the middle section right over here so
minus 5. so this is the number
the number of
yellow
cubes it feels weird to write the word
yellow and green the number of yellow
cubes or another way to think about it
and we could just you could just do this
math right here 12 plus 13 minus 5 is
what it's it's 20 right is did i do that
right 12 minus yep it's 20. so that's
one way you just get this is equal to 20
over 29 but the more interesting thing
than even the answer or prob of the
probability of getting that is
expressing this in terms of the other
probabilities that we figured out
earlier in the video
so let's think about this a little bit
we can rewrite this fraction right over
here we can rewrite this as 12
over 29
plus 13
plus 13 over 29
minus 5 over 29
minus 5 over
minus 5 over 29 and this was the number
of yellow over the total possibilities
so this right over here was the
probability of getting a yellow
this right over here was the number of
cubes over the total possibilities so
this is plus the probability of getting
of getting a cube
the probability of getting a cube
and this right over here is the number
of yellow cubes over the total
possibilities so this right over here
was
minus the probability of yellow and
and a cube and let me write it that way
minus the probability
of
yellow i'll write yellow and yellow
yellow and
yellow
and
getting a cube
yellow and getting a cube and so what
we've just done here and you could play
with the numbers the numbers i just used
as an example right here to make things
a little bit concrete but you can see
this is a generalizable thing if we have
the probability of
one condition or another condition so
let me rewrite it the probability and
i'll just write a little bit more
generally here this gives us an
interesting idea the probability of
getting one condition of a of an object
being a member of set a
or
or a member of set b is equal to the
probability that it is a member of set a
plus the probability that it is a member
of set b
minus the probability that it is a
member of both
mine is the probability that is a member
of
both and this is a really useful result
i think sometimes it's called like the
addition rule of probability but i
wanted to show you it's a completely
common sense thing the reason why you
can't just add these two probabilities
is because they might have some overlap
there's a probability of getting both
and if you just added both of these you
would be double counting that overlap
which we've already seen earlier in this
video so you have to subtract one
version of the overlap out so you are
not double counting it
and i'll throw other one other idea out
sometimes you have possibilities that
have no overlap so let's say this is a
set of all possibilities this is the set
of all possibilities and let's say this
is the set that meets condition a let's
say this is set that means condition a
and let this is let me do this in a
different color and let's say that this
is the set that meets condition b so in
this situation there is no overlap
there's no way nothing is a member of
both set a and b so in this situation
the probability of a and b is zero there
is no overlap
and these type these type of
conditions or these two events are
called mutually exclusive
mutually
exclusive so if events are mutually
exclusive that means that they both
cannot happen at the same time there's
no there's no event that meets both of
these conditions and if things are
mutually con exclusive
then you can say the probability of a or
b is the probability of a plus b because
this thing is zero but if things are not
mutually exclusive you would have to
subtract out the overlap an easy the
probably the best way to think about it
is to just always realize that you have
to subtract out the overlap and
obviously if something is mutually
exclusive the probability of getting a
and b is going to be 0.